[Música]
a una semana de que termine el mandato
presidencial en eeuu a la cámara de
representantes iniciará hoy el segundo
proceso de impeachment contra donald
trump en cuatro años esta vez por
incitar al asedio del capitolio el 6 de
enero el proceso se desencadenó tras la
negativa del vicepresidente mike pence
de asumir el poder con la enmienda 25
en américa latina los médicos hacen
huelga en perú por la crisis de kobe 19
brasil que produce la vacuna china
sinovac con apenas de 50% de efectividad
se queda sin opciones para iniciar en el
corto plazo una campaña de inmunización
y en bolivia del ex presidente evo
morales dio positivo para el virus
y alexéi navalni volverá a rusia el
opositor del kremlin a anunció su
retorno desde alemania el próximo día 17
tras recuperarse del envenenamiento que
sufrió el pasado 20 de agosto por el que
responsabiliza a vladimir putin a su
llegada a enfrentar a acusaciones de
corrupción bajo amenaza de cárcel
comienza la mañana y también las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez y arrancamos el informativo
con noticias de eeuu por segunda vez en
este periodo presidencial los demócratas
intentarán que donald trump sea
destituido tras la negativa del
vicepresidente mike pence aa asumir el
poder por medio de la enmienda 25 la
cámara se reunirá hoy para iniciar el
proceso de impeachment esta vez por
incitar al asalto del capitolio del
pasado 6 de enero dejando un saldo de 5
muertos y más de 80 procesados al menos
5 republicanos se unieron a este nuevo
impulso para sacar a trump del poder
cuando falta una semana para la posesión
de joe bait
la insto a usted ya cada miembro del
congreso para que eviten acciones que
puedan dividir y avivar aún más las
pasiones del momento trabaje con
nosotros para rebajar la temperatura y
unir a nuestro país mientras nos
preparamos para investir al presidente
electo yo bayrén como el próximo
presidente de eeuu precisamente por
incitar a la violencia después del
asalto al capitolio es que youtube
suspendió el canal de donald trump algo
que viola las políticas de la red social
el mandatario ya había sido excluido
permanentemente de twitter en su modo de
comunicación favorito y su cuenta de
facebook fue suspendida por dos semanas
el presidente dijo que las acciones son
una afrenta contra la libertad de
expresión
cambio de tema a partir de hoy 13 de
enero los médicos de perú darán inicio a
una huelga indefinida el gremio le exige
al gobierno interino del presidente
francisco sagasti mejores condiciones
laborales una medida de presión que
llega tras negociaciones infructuosas
con el ministerio de salud y en pleno
pico de hospitalizaciones por kobe 19 el
país se declaró en segunda ola de
pandemia en el último día hubo casi tres
mil positivos y 64 muertes
brasil se queda sin posibilidades de
inmunización en el corto plazo pues la
única alianza que tenía a la mano era la
de sinovac el medicamento chino que
actualmente se desarrolla en el país
latino pero un estudio mostró sólo 50 4%
de efectividad para prevenir infecciones
sintomáticas los datos revelados por los
ensayos clínicos estarían apenas en el
margen de aprobación regulatoria y
quedan muy por debajo de lo esperado una
gran decepción para brasil que esperaba
iniciar la inoculación con esa
farmacéutica
y el presidente boliviano evo morales se
dio positivo para kobe 19 su oficina
emitió un comunicado informando que el
líder está estable y que ya recibe
tratamiento para combatir los síntomas
la semana pasada morales de 61 años
participó en reuniones grupales con
cocaleros en cochabamba en la parte
central del país
bolivia afronta una segunda ola de
contagios por la pandemia que ha llegado
a superar los 2000 positivos diarios ya
son casi 10.000 muertos por kobe de en
el país
en europa italia está al borde de la
crisis política el gobierno está
preparado para aprobar un plan de
estímulo por valor de 220 mil millones
de euros dirigido a ayudar el país a
recuperarse de la pandemia pero los
partidos políticos de la coalición del
primer ministro giuseppe conte no están
de acuerdo en cómo debe gastarse ese
dinero
las tensiones en el seno de la coalición
gobernante en italia han alcanzado un
nuevo pico los días de conversaciones
para salvar las diferencias entre el
primer ministro conté y uno de los
partidos claves en la coalición han
fracasado ambas partes han estado
discutiendo sobre como el país debería
gastar los miles de millones de euros
del paquete de estímulo contra el cob y
19 ahora el ex primer ministro matteo
renzi líder del partido viva italia dice
que está preparado para marcharse un
movimiento que podría acabar con el
gobierno de conte
no seremos cómplices del ejemplo más
descarado del mal uso de fondos públicos
en la historia de italia si queremos
avanzar necesitamos tener un plan bajo
una presión creciente con te ha
reescrito el plan de recuperación
doblando la financiación tanto para el
sistema sanitario como para el turismo y
aumentando el porcentaje de inversiones
sin embargo rehn si no cede y amenaza
con la posible renuncia de ministros
procedentes de su formación en respuesta
el primer ministro podría tratar de
remodelar su gabinete o presentar su
dimisión para buscar una rápida
reelección al frente de un nuevo
gobierno si esto fracasa el presidente
mataré la podría ser forzado a disolver
el parlamento y convocar nuevas
elecciones una opción que podría desatar
el caos político mientras italia
continúa luchando contra el commit 19
que ha dejado casi 80.000 muertos en el
país el crítico del kremlin alexéi
navalni anunció su regreso a rusia el 17
de enero desde alemania donde se
recupera tras ser víctima de
envenenamiento en agosto pasado el
gobierno ruso niega cualquier
participación en el incidente naval y se
expone a enfrentar procesos legales que
lo podrían llevar a la
las autoridades rusas pidieron a un
tribunal que lo encarcelará por violar
los términos de una sentencia suspendida
tras una condena por fraude que él dijo
tuvo motivos políticos
lo último que putin puede hacer es poner
un cartel gigante increíble que diga al
excel no vuelvas a casa bajo ninguna
circunstancia en nuevo presidio mal pero
venir a alemania no fue mi decisión es
un buen país pero no estoy aquí por
voluntad propia estoy aquí porque
trataron de matarme aquellas personas
que tienen un problema contra mí porque
no pudieron matarnos y sobreviví y ahora
amenazan con meterme a la cárcel recojo
taxis por primera vez en cinco años el
presidente de venezuela nicolás maduro
ofreció su discurso anual ante los
integrantes de la asamblea nacional que
ahora es de mayoría oficialista en sus
palabras el jefe de estado aseguró que
2021 será el año de la recuperación el
opositor juan guaidó dijo que maduro
debería rendir cuentas informe de luís
méndez
fuimos por primera vez en 5 años el
presidente nicolás maduro entregó su
informe de gobierno ante la asamblea
nacional el mandatario venezolano
defendió su gestión de la pandemia del
cómic 19 debemos actuar en conjunto
he pedido a la comisión presidencial y
pido a esta asamblea que nos apoye nos
ayude tomaron conjunta acciones
orientadas al perfeccionamiento del
modelo 77 a la ampliación de los
tratamientos para la cura de los nuevos
contagiados de manera universal como
debe ser maduro agregó que unas 10
millones de dosis de la vacuna rusa
estarían por llegar a venezuela en los
próximos días en su mensaje a la nación
maduro aseguró que 2021 sería el año de
la recuperación de venezuela de cuya
crisis responsabilizó a las sanciones de
eeuu y la unión europea pasamos de tener
más de 50 mil millones de dólares en
2013 a disponer apenas de 743 millones
en el año 2020 quiere decir de cada 100
dólares o euros que el país obtenía por
la venta de petróleo en 2014 hoy o tiene
un poco más de un dólar por su parte el
líder opositor venezolano juan guaidó
quien es reconocido por más de 60 países
como el presidente
legítimo de venezuela arremetió en
twitter en contra de maduro ante las
mentiras del dictador en la imagen un
resumen por lo que debe rendir cuentas a
la justicia delitos de lesa humanidad
terrorismo y narcotráfico con recompensa
de 15 millones de dólares mientras que
la asamblea nacional estuvo bajo el
control de la oposición entre 2016 y
el presidente venezolano nicolás maduro
solamente acudió al parlamento en una
ocasión 2016 y allí debió afrontar los
cuestionamientos del entonces presidente
del legislativo el opositor henry ramos
ayuda
y en los deportes esa noche river plate
se quedó a las puertas de una histórica
remontada en la vuelta de semifinales en
la copa libertadores el conjunto
'millonario' se impuso 0 12 en casa de
palmeiras pero aunque sufrieron los
brasileños defendieron la ventaja
conseguida en la ida fue un encuentro
marcado por la polémica con el bar
anulando el tercer gol de river y un
posterior penalti
palmeiras avanza hacía su primera final
en 20 años y espera rival del duelo de
este miércoles entre santos y boca
juniors la gran final será el 30 de
enero en el estadio maracaná
hasta aquí el informativo regresamos en
minutos siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]